data protection regulation topped
discussions on friday 13th during the
second and last day of the justice and
home affairs council in brussels
eu justice ministers reached a partial
general approach on some issues linked
to data protection
they expressed their support for the
creation of a one-stop shop mechanism
that will play a role in important
cross-border cases
it will also provide for cooperation and
joint decision making between data
protection authorities
this system would allow citizens to
launch complaints with regulators in
their country of residence
the latvian justice minister welcomed
the progress made during a news
conference after chairing the meeting
thanks to the one-stop agency principal
that is
fundamentally new in data protection
persons are insured
protection of their rights within easy
reach
in case of infringement
citizens will have
a possibility to contact
an authority of their country
data protection in the european union is
a fundamental right
that is why its legislative reform seeks
to ensure a very high level of
protection of personal data